hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to another try not to
laugh challenge i'm gonna make another
promise that i can't keep and i'm gonna
say that i'm a stone cold bastard with
ice in my soul and no joy in my face
and we're gonna ignore the fact that i'm
actually a giggly [__] that laughs in
my own poop jokes and we're gonna skate
on
try to watch these videos and get
through them just fine also if you
didn't know already you can now become a
sponsor of this channel
if you want to help me make cool videos
like who killed markiplier and a date
with markiplier you can click the big
blue sponsor button down below right by
the subscribe button
and it'll show you a full list of perks
that you get if you are a sponsor not
only do you get a special heart by your
name to help you stand out whenever you
comment
you also get access to emojis sponsor
only videos live streams merch merch
discount and you get access to a special
community tab
that helps me talk directly to you guys
if you're on mobile and you can't find
the big blue sponsor button then i'll
put a link in the description as well so
thank you everybody so much for
sponsoring and helping me make cool
stuff
now on to the videos
[Music]
foreign
not funny
oh
[Music]
um
that's not loving i want to be very
clear that's not laughing that's not me
laughing i'm not laughing there
look what engines are happening oh right
it's got a lot point one let's see who
care about it don't leave that
that that's not going to make me laugh
that'll solidify my reputation it's just
somebody laughs at poop jokes
i'm just so impressed with this dog's
ability to [__] on the run like that is
just goddamn amazing
[Music]
foreign
i mean there were subtitles so that
helped but you know what i mean i
kind of understand the formation of
never
[Music]
the mind
[Laughter]
if they weren't laughing
oh my god oh man the weird thing about
the we think about that one is like my
brain was like it's not a face it's a
face it's not a
it's a face it's not a face it would
like shift in and when when my brain
would
be like face i'd laugh or i wouldn't
laugh but i almost
i i felt the laugh energy coming up
the poor baby oh kid whatever you're
doing don't do it
okay this is a bad idea whatever's
happening is a bad idea
[Music]
hmm
good girl good girl
good bestie you're a good
girl good bestie
hey sadie
that's a hundred percent chica oh it's
cute
oh my god dad this doesn't have your
name on it
kids won't you step outside for a second
[Music]
what do you want huh you want some money
take it oh [__] oh
pretty good pretty impressive very
impressive
you wanna know how i got these scars
nope if you hungry
[Music]
say yeah
oh that's cute
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god that's the greatest thing i've
ever seen in my life
oh my goodness gracious bless that man
no no what we've got here is the mark
one tank
it's actually the very first tank ever
built in 1916
and they were used for the first time in
the battle of slayer course
on the somme on the 15th of september
1916.
[Music]
take care of the baby
so you want to grab a drink or something
dog
ah nah i'm good okay no problem y'all
[Music]
did
come on
i can't get away from it this kitchen is
filthy
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]
richard thank you that's very kind of
you to say that
okay is he in there
no the coast is
snake
[Music]
you are pathetic when he died i was so
sad that i would never hear that voice
again
his laugh
his funny little requests touch me
his reprimands touch me harder
this one is made to look like a gate
something very bizarre
what the [__] oh no
[Laughter]
oh my god
this one is made to look like a thing
well [__] ah how about that
[Applause]
[__] yeah give us another one
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus christ aaron fine [__]
all right
i got this new anime plot basically
there's this high school girl except
she's got huge boobs
i mean some serious hunkers a real set
of badonkas
packing some doba and hunkeros massive
the hunka bankaloos
big old tanahan guerra cougars what
happens next transfer student shows up
one day with even bigger bug hanukkah
whoops
humongous hungalanga no no lugongas
who's that
[Laughter]
cougars what happens next transfer
student shows up one day with even
bigger bunk hanukkah hoops
i don't know just silly words and poop
jokes that's all it takes to make me
laugh that's all it is really
it's really nothing complicated i am not
a complicated individual
anyway but thank you everybody so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed this as
much as i did if you got other funny
videos you want me to
watch put them in the comments below and
also like i said at the beginning if you
want to sponsor the channel and help me
out a great deal
press that big sponsor button down below
or click the link in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out the other try not to laughs
that i've done in the playlist
over there so thanks again and as always
i will see you
in the next video bye-bye